[MUSIC PLAYING]
PAUL YOUNG: There's been a
bunch of announcements already.
If you've been
watching the keynotes,
SAP's got a lot of
attention from us.
Without going into all
the detail, in fact
I am actually doing a
speech tomorrow afternoon
talking about where we
are technology-wise and
platform-wise with SAP.
So come to that one.
Bring your friends.
So without going into all
that detail, all I'll say
is we've come a long
way in 12 months.
So nine months ago
at Next San Francisco
last year, we launched
the 4-terabyte servers
with the promise that we'd have
the 12 terabytes this year,
and then the 18 terabytes.
Obviously, we
announced yesterday
we've made the 12 terabytes
available to early access
customers.
That's just a huge [INAUDIBLE]
the only 12-terabyte VMs
in market, the
largest VMs in market.
We really are setting the pace
for the industry at this point.
And then from a
customer perspective,
I have to tell you,
my objective here
was not just to go out
and randomly take anyone.
My objective was, look,
I've been in this market
a long time.
What happens generally for SAP
customers is they come to you
and say, well, I know you have
a customer that's like me,
but I'm bigger than them.
And so are you really--
can you handle me?
And so that was one
of our challenges
as we came in the
market, was how
do you convince this market
that we're serious about SAP
and that we can handle
everybody without this taking
five years for us to build.
And so objective number
one for me was, let's
not just go find anyone.
Let's take the largest customers
that we can find, and let's
convince them that, A, Google
Cloud is serious, and B,
we can run their
SAP environments.
And we did that.
As you're about
to see here, we've
rolled out a bunch
of names already,
more to come over time.
But we got some of
the largest customers
on the planet, two of which
are represented here today.
And that would be the
second part, which
is the extended part
of this strategy,
frankly, is that I
thoroughly believe
that SAP customers
don't actually
buy from salespeople, that SAP
customers are a giant club,
and they buy from each other.
One of them does something.
And if it's successful,
they tell all their friends,
and all their friends
choose to do it too.
And so objective number
one was find the largest
customers on the
planet and convince
them to come to Google Cloud.
Objective number two was
let them tell their stories.
And so that's
today's subject, is
let's bring two
customers up on stage
to tell their story
of what they're
doing with SAP and Google Cloud
so you can learn from them
and hear it from the customer's
mouth instead from our mouths.
So with that, I'd
like to welcome
on stage Meena Kishanchandani--
I got it right this time?
I got it right both
times, apparently--
Meena, who is with McKesson
Technology, and Timo Salzsieder
from Metronom or Metro Group.
[APPLAUSE]
MEENA KISHANCHANDANI: Sorry.
PAUL YOUNG: It's OK.
You doing OK?
MEENA KISHANCHANDANI: Yeah.
PAUL YOUNG: Cool.
No, I had a little bit
of a fall last night.
So I need some
more time to walk.
PAUL YOUNG: Yeah.
Well, you can hold the mic.
Yeah, Meena-- I got
an email last night
from Meena that said,
I fell last night
trying to get into the lift,
and I might not make it there.
I'm like, ooh, that
doesn't sound good.
So I honestly appreciate
you making the effort.
I will also qualify, by
the way, that Meena said,
I hadn't drunk any
alcohol at the time.
There was no need to
qualify, but she did
qualify when she arrived today.
MEENA KISHANCHANDANI:
Exactly, because I thought,
that's the natural question
that comes to mind.
PAUL YOUNG: I assumed nothing.
I only had concern
when I got the email.
But anyway, there you go.
So really quickly, first
of all, both of you,
thank you for giving
us your time today.
You've actually both been
very generous with your time,
both here and previously.
As I said, one of the great
things for me about SAP
is it is a giant community
where the customers all
do work with each other.
Equally, Google is very
good at that community,
and you've both given time
gracefully and gratefully
already.
So I really do appreciate
what you do for us.
That said, generally, I will
say that in any SAP project,
technology is part of it.
And we're Google Cloud.
We like to talk
about technology.
But a lot of this is
about people, right?
And it's about people leading,
and it's about people,
as a group, changing.
So I think people
become important.
So instead of just
piling into technology,
can we get a little
background from you
on what's your
career history, how
do you get here, what's
your current role, what
are you doing, so we
get a sense of you?
MEENA KISHANCHANDANI: Sure.
So I have been with McKesson
for about a dozen years now.
And prior to that, I was
based out of Midwest,
working for a utility company
as a database architect.
So that's what my background is.
And then when I
joined McKesson, I
joined as a database architect
in SAP technology team,
essentially a BASIS team, not
having any background in SAP
whatsoever.
In fact, the first day I joined
McKesson, I looked around,
and I just asked people,
what's SAP BASIS?
So that's where
I started in SAP.
But very quickly, within a year,
I crossed over to the SAP area
and grew in that
technology space.
And then over time, I've
had a lot of opportunities
at McKesson, and then I've led
the SAP technology teams there.
And then along the way, I
also took over, actually,
some data analytics
responsibilities
and stood up a service
within McKesson on prem.
We started some cloud expansion
work on that front as well,
and that continues to go on.
Very recently, I've transitioned
everything I previously had,
and now my role is just
purely to focus on our ERP
transformation in
North America, and also
to support our European
ERP journey as well.
They've already started on S/4.
But primarily, that's going
to be my focus going forward.
PAUL YOUNG: So no pressure.
You're only responsible for the
entire operating environment
of McKesson for the future.
MEENA KISHANCHANDANI: Well,
if you put it that way--
[LAUGHS]
PAUL YOUNG: I think
it's true, but anyway--
oh, you're responsible
for delivering it, anyway.
MEENA KISHANCHANDANI:
Yeah, so-- no, it's a team.
It's a very, very large
and talented-- not large,
I should say.
It's a very, very talented team.
It's not as large
as it needs to be.
But no, it's all the team.
PAUL YOUNG: Thanks.
And Timo?
TIMO SALZSIEDER: Yeah,
I'm the chief solution
officer at Metro.
And I actually like
that title quite a lot
because a second title is
chief information officer-- so
CIO of the organization.
But chief solution officer
represents a bit more
what I'm doing because I'm
not only in charge of IT,
but also on product
and user experience.
So that means I run the
entire product organization
within Metro.
We are pretty large.
Within my organization, there
are 2 and 1/2 thousand people
purely in IT and UX, et cetera.
And I'm in this role now
since almost two years,
so I'm pretty new.
Before that, I was basically
only in the digital space--
so building a lot of
tools and products
probably not known
here in the US.
But for example, Xing, that's
a European version of LinkedIn.
So I was there also on
the supervisory board,
so a lot of digital background.
Studied actually
computer science
here on the corner in
Berkeley, so I feel a bit
at home just a bit, actually.
And yeah, doing this, as
I said, for two years now,
and we're in the middle of
the digital transformation.
And I think that's
the reason why
Metro approached me and
asked whether I would like
to work for this organization.
Because one of my task
is, obviously, to drive--
and we'll talk, I think, in
a minute about Metro itself--
but SAP.
I mean, we are a
German-based company.
And as German company, you
have to have, somewhere, SAP.
So therefore, we're using SAP
mainly in the financial sector.
There are some changes,
without pulling too much
into this direction
because I have
a feeling that some SAP
salespeople are chasing me
around the globe.
Because it might be
that we also introduce
SAP retail in the near
future, because so far,
we have a custom-developed
solution running
our merchandising environment.
But yeah, we are an SAP shop
when it comes to finance,
and I think that's the
reason why I'm sitting here.
PAUL YOUNG: Yeah, and I think,
really, the next question
is just to set the scale.
Because I think
Metro is effectively
an "everywhere in
the world except US"
brand, if you were chasing
it through right now.
Giant retail, and you
guys were number two.
You just split into
two companies, right?
But before that, you were
actually the number two
retailer in Europe.
So do you just want
to give the audience
just a perspective
on who Metro is
and the scale you operate at?
TIMO SALZSIEDER: OK, don't
want to go too back in history
because, I mean, we are a
60, 70-years-old company.
Had really a huge footprint.
We decide now to
focus very strong,
so the focus is now really
on our core business,
which is wholesale.
So that means we're a
wholesale company acting in 35
countries around the globe.
Not in the US, as
you mentioned, but we
are very strong in Europe
and very strong in Asia.
So emerging markets
for us are China.
India, for example,
we are very strong.
And obviously in our
home base in Germany,
we are pretty strong, but
also in France and Italy
and Spain and Russia, et cetera.
So 35 countries, and it's
a pretty big organization.
So we have $37 billion
revenue, currently,
euro-- so around $38 billion US.
We have 150,000 people, and
in also very exotic markets
like Myanmar or
Pakistan, et cetera.
So therefore, it's usually quite
hard for me to get into the US
because I have the stamp
from Pakistan in my passport,
and it's not that easy
to get into the country.
But yeah, so pretty big
organization, and whole food
is our core business.
And coming obviously
from brick-and-mortar,
and my responsibility is now to
move this into the omnichannel
road--
so therefore,
invest quite heavily
currently into
online shops and apps
and all this kind of stuff.
PAUL YOUNG: Cool.
I mean, effectively, you are--
for the US audience in the room,
the business model for you,
at this point, is effectively,
you're Costco, right?
You're--
TIMO SALZSIEDER: Yes.
PAUL YOUNG: Well,
you would argue
you've existed a long
time before Costco did,
but the equivalent
business in the US is--
TIMO SALZSIEDER: Yeah,
so Costco, Cisco--
so these are the
equivalents here in the US.
The problem we are
facing is, as I said,
we are in different countries.
And we're running,
unfortunately,
not one business
model, which would be
great from an IT perspective.
But in some countries,
it's more a B2C business.
Where in other countries,
a classical B2B business.
And mainly restaurants,
hotels, caterers,
these are our
classical customers.
And as I said, we're running
different business models,
and that makes it
extremely hard.
Because we have a
central IT serving
these more than 30 countries
with different business models,
and that makes it very
complex to standardize.
But that's one of the reasons
why we focus very much on SAP,
because this is the
standard solution,
and we want to simplify
our process landscape.
PAUL YOUNG: Thanks.
And then Meena, McKesson is--
again, McKesson's a
fascinating company.
Fortune 6, sixth largest
company in America, and it's
amazing the number of people I
meet who say, who are McKesson?
MEENA KISHANCHANDANI: Exactly.
Yeah, so as you mentioned,
it's a Fortune 6 company
with revenues of close
to, I think, $210 billion.
And it's been in business
for over, I think, 185 years.
I don't know exact
number by now.
Who's counting?
But so we primarily deliver--
basically, one-third of
prescription medicines
in North America are
delivered by McKesson.
Then we also have a
pretty large offering
in our brand and private label
of medical/surgical supplies.
Then we operate in the specialty
health care space as well,
supporting upwards of, I
think, 9,000-plus oncologists
and specialists
throughout our networks.
And then we also
support a large number
of independently owned and
banner pharmacies as well.
We are about, from an
employee strength perspective,
I think we are about
78,000-plus at the moment.
And we operate across
16 countries right now.
So yeah.
So yeah, that's it.
PAUL YOUNG: And again,
just to give you
a perspective on McKesson, I
think even inside Google when
we started working with
McKesson, a lot of people
were like, who are McKesson?
What do you do?
Because I used to call
on McKesson with my SAP
badge on back in the days.
But the question I always put
to people, if you can just
imagine this, is--
so think about
your local hospital
or your local doctor's office,
your local dental offices.
You'll understand
all the consumables
they go through every day
in terms of saline bags
and gloves and needles
and everything they need.
And then if you've
never questioned it,
wonder, why is there
not a giant warehouse
attached to those hospitals?
And the simple answer
is-- the reason,
because McKesson
is that warehouse.
I mean, for eight hours a day,
pretty much every hospital
or doctor's office,
dentist office, whatever,
calls McKesson and says, I
need these things tomorrow
or in the next 40 hours.
And it goes out.
I mean, and this
is part of the--
I want to reinforce this.
It's not just the scale of these
two customers and who they are
and what we're taking on
here, but also crucially,
where reliability and
performance are everything,
right?
If Metro stops working,
there's a lot of restaurants
that just stop working.
And there's a lot
of people, frankly,
that don't eat because of it.
If McKesson stops working,
operations get canceled.
We have huge issues.
Hospitals don't keep
the supplies in stock.
They look at their schedule,
and they order to your operation
having being scheduled.
So when people come back and
go, wow, is the cloud ready,
this isn't just, hey, it's a
little side accounting system.
We're talking serious
economic impact and challenge
if we don't do it right.
This is a huge step for us.
MEENA KISHANCHANDANI:
Absolutely.
What comes to mind is
a couple of years ago,
we had a leadership
conference here.
And our CEO came to talk to us.
And somebody asked him, what
are your topmost priorities
that IT can be working on?
And he kind of just
looked point blank at us.
He's like, don't break
anything, and don't
let anyone steal anything.
So that's our expectation
of Google as well.
That's the table stakes for us.
Yeah, because those operations--
excellence is a huge
part of our culture.
And that's very,
very important to us.
PAUL YOUNG: Yeah,
"don't steal anything"
was in reference to the data.
MEENA KISHANCHANDANI: Yes.
PAUL YOUNG: Because you also
have a huge amount of data on--
MEENA KISHANCHANDANI:
Absolutely, yeah.
PAUL YOUNG: --people and
their medical conditions,
and everything else.
No pressure.
No pressure on me.
And anyway, so thanks for that.
Equally, the other thing
I think is fascinating
here is two industries,
health care and retail,
where these are not industries
you go to retire in,
effectively.
These are industries that are
in massive change, globally.
And I think that leads us into
the conversation too, which
is this time last year, a lot
of the conversation I got was
lift and shift, lift and shift.
We just need to lift
and shift what we have
and move it into the cloud.
I think in both of your cases,
there is no lift and shift
here.
We're talking massive projects.
And along the way, your
business and your industry
is changing rapidly, and so you
have to deal with that change
as well.
Do you want to just quickly
highlight what keeps you awake
at night in that context?
MEENA KISHANCHANDANI: Yeah.
Obviously, I mean, health care
is such a rapidly changing--
at such a rapid scale.
It's becoming increasingly
high-tech and very tech-savvy.
Also, our consumers
are demanding more.
They have a lot more power.
And then we have a large
set of aging population
across the globe.
And then you have these
government agencies
and regulators
constantly changing
the rules and policies on us.
So you have to be able to
quickly adapt to those changes
and quickly deliver
to those requirements.
So IT can have a pretty
large, impactful role
to enable our business to be
able to meet those demands.
So yeah, so the
change is constant,
and that's what we are
seeing continuously.
And that's where
we need to focus
on modernizing our
architectures to be
able to meet the needs
of the business demands.
PAUL YOUNG: Yeah.
And Timo, yeah, retail's an
easy life these days, right?
Not much change going on?
TIMO SALZSIEDER: Absolutely.
No.
In fact, we are facing
huge issues in front of us.
So I think in the past,
it was quite easy.
I mean, you just sold your
stuff, and you're all set.
These days, things are
changing radically.
So particularly in our markets,
if you look into Asia--
I mean, I think a lot of
innovation out of retail
is coming, in the
meantime, out of China.
So for example, the usage
of mobile devices in China
is completely different
than in Europe
and I also believe in the US.
So it's pretty normal that I
know an 80-year-old woman gets
to a store, and she's
having her mobile phone
and paying with her
mobile phone and scanning
product, et cetera.
So that's pretty normal.
So the speed of
innovation pushed out
of these markets and
competitors like Alibaba--
so long-term
competitors, or Amazon.
I mean, they're pushing
hard into that direction.
They bring a lot of
innovation to that space.
And for us, we really try
to be an omnichannel player.
So therefore, we have this
brick-and-mortar business
with huge stores
around the globe.
And what we need to do is
obviously drive our customers
a bit more into this
omnichannel world.
And this makes it
quite difficult.
Also, coming also from
more B2C background,
I just figured out that
obviously, the customer
behavior is completely
different in our world.
So it's not that customers
are searching for a product.
If a restaurant owner
gets into our stores,
he or she knows exactly
what they're looking for.
So therefore, completely
different customer behavior.
They don't want to spend
too much time in a store.
So they want to, obviously,
get in and get out
as fast as possible with
the best price and the best
customer experience.
And so therefore,
optimizing, for example,
the checkout process
at the cashier
is one of the topics we're
bringing a lot of technology
currently in--
so a lot of, also, AI technology
like vision APIs, et cetera,
just to detect products.
Also running a lot
of innovation when
it comes to augmented realities,
so you take your mobile phone,
put it on a product,
and then you
get some additional
information on the product.
So this kind of topics are
brand new to our world.
And obviously, this
is a huge change
within our internal processes,
and also in the mindset.
So when it comes
to agility and--
I don't know-- self-organized
teams, et cetera,
these are the topics.
And as I said, we're a
pretty old organization.
And if you want to transform the
organization into a very fast,
high-speed organization,
this is also
one of the challenges
that keeps me awake.
PAUL YOUNG: Yeah, cool.
We'll come back to
that one in a second.
So I wasn't joking at the
start where I said, for me,
the answer was, let's get
the biggest customers we can,
and let's prove we can do this.
Both of you represent, on the
stage, [INAUDIBLE] to SAP.
Do you want to just
give people a sense
on, statistically, where you are
at with your SAP installations?
TIMO SALZSIEDER:
So we are running
not only one SAP installation.
We're running multiple.
As I said, we have this
decentralized environment.
So what we're doing currently
with SAP, and in context
on Google Cloud, is that we
are consolidating more than 100
different accounting systems.
And you just heard
that I'm saying
we have 25 or 30 countries.
And you might ask yourself,
OK, 25 or 30 countries,
why we run 100 different
accounting systems?
So consolidation of these
systems is quite hard for us,
and we expect that
this project will
take three to five years to
consolidate all these systems.
If you look in the cost
center infrastructure,
the numbers of cost centers
we have across the globe
are more than 10,000.
So to consolidate them
into a couple of hundred
is already a big challenge.
So this is where we are, and
we started this whole journey
about 12 months
ago where we said,
OK, let's look how the future
of our SAP installation will be.
And we have the general
strategy to move towards cloud.
So we're doing this, obviously,
not only in SAP world,
but also in our digital
initiatives when it comes
to online sales, et cetera.
But now we are in the
middle of that journey,
and it's pretty clear
that we're moving into SAP
S/4HANA on Google Cloud.
And this is where
we are right now.
And yeah, project just started
about a couple of months ago.
We're still in the
conceptual phase
and currently very close to
bringing the first country
live, and then
obviously continue
with rolling out
the solution to all
of the rest of the countries.
PAUL YOUNG: Yeah, I mean,
it's a huge project.
It's funny, when we published
an article about you,
and the number of phone
calls I got from SAP people
and customers who came
back and said, wait,
it has to be a typo.
That article says there are
more than 100 individual SAP
systems.
Historically, it was
completely decentralized.
And they're
consolidating it to one.
And for the record,
there's only two customers
I know of globally
that are doing this.
You're one of them.
There's another one that's
not public who's doing this.
But I mean, it is a--
you mean, with all
the stuff we just
talked about changing
your industry,
the complexity that's involved
in doing all of those changes
and bringing them all together.
And inevitably, I think--
maybe I'm wrong, but my
perspective on your project,
for a lot of people,
you start this project
with a destination.
It's unlikely to be the actual
destination you end up at,
right?
Because the world's going
to change in the meantime.
And so a lot of what
hopefully we're doing for you
and a lot of what you need
is the flexibility, right?
It's the understanding that
there is no set destination,
and the ability
to change rapidly
at all layers in
the stack is what's
going to get you where
you need to get to.
Is that that fair?
TIMO SALZSIEDER: Yeah.
So scalability, flexibility-- so
these are the keywords for us.
Obviously, we're also interested
in nobody stealing stuff
from us.
But frankly, this is a core
requirement on our side.
So we really want
to do much more.
And therefore, Google is, for
us, not only a strategic part
when it comes to our
finance SAP role.
It's also an overall
strategic partner.
So long-term, we plan to
move basically everything
into the cloud.
So that's a clear strategy here.
And therefore, there's
a high demand also
when it comes to cultural
aspects, collaboration,
innovation, these kind of
topics with SAP and Google.
And therefore, we're pushing
hard on these topics.
But you're right.
It's a very complex process.
This will take, as I
said, a couple of years
to finalize that one.
And the biggest challenge
is not only technology,
also convince the people
that is the right way to go.
So I have a lot of CFOs sitting
in the countries telling me
that this is a
pretty stupid idea,
that they want to sit on
their existing processes
and infrastructure.
And therefore, we
need to convince also
these kind of people,
making sure that everybody's
following the same path.
But standardization
and harmonization
and simplification of
the processes, this
is a clear target of Metro.
PAUL YOUNG: Meena, you want
to run the statistics package
on SAP for McKesson?
MEENA KISHANCHANDANI:
For McKesson, do I?
Yeah.
Yeah, it's considered
as, I think,
amongst the top three or
five, or something like that.
So it's a pretty
large install base
that we have of SAP across
Europe and North America.
We're probably close
to, I want to say, maybe
30-plus products that
are either deployed
or on their way to be deployed.
And probably close to
upwards of 260 SAP instances
that we have, and I'm sure
every day, the number changes.
And one of our largest--
PAUL YOUNG: 260
production systems?
MEENA KISHANCHANDANI: No,
sorry, non-production, but--
PAUL YOUNG: Non-production, OK.
Cool.
MEENA KISHANCHANDANI:
But I'll talk
about why the non-production
is also important.
Because in North America,
one of our ECC instances
is upwards of 100 terabytes.
And when you think about the
entire landscape-- and most
of them, except for development,
is a copy of production.
So you're talking big-scale.
And if you're
talking about cloud,
I mean, that's
just not going to--
that's just impossible
to move, lift, and shift.
And also, that system currently
supports transaction volumes
close to-- if I think
about peak lines,
it's, I want to say, close to
2 million line items a day.
And that too, most
of the processing
is done within the four
to six-hour peak time.
And then availability,
I think it's almost a 24
by 7 requirement,
which we're not
achieving that because we
do have some maintenance
windows on the weekend,
a very short one,
which now the business, we're
getting a lot of pressure
to eliminate that.
So we will be
looking to Google--
PAUL YOUNG: [INAUDIBLE]
MEENA KISHANCHANDANI:
--to help us with that.
And then we're also very,
very large HANA shop.
We've had HANA deployed
in our environment,
I think, since 2014.
It's probably one of the
largest BW and HANA system
that we have.
It's 24 terabytes.
And a bunch of other HANA
systems, and we also--
transactional systems, I should
say, that's a suite on HANA.
So the point being that
we do have a good amount
of talent in HANA skills.
And then as we look
at our S/4 journey
right now, where that started,
for the UK implementation,
that's a completely
greenfield implementation.
So that's starting on GCP.
It has already started on GCP.
When it comes to
North America, I
think we have to see, get the
experience with getting our UK
environment on GCP
and learn from that,
and then take those learnings
and bring them back and plan
our journey here.
Yeah, so that's where
we are just mostly--
North America, mostly
forming norming stage.
UK, we've started.
PAUL YOUNG: Yeah,
it's fascinating.
Because for both of you,
the ultimate destination
is the same, which is
effectively, in your case,
one giant S/4
system; in your case,
probably two-- one for
Europe, and one for America.
But the two journeys are
just radically different,
and fascinating as it goes.
So I think one of the things--
obviously, there's
a bunch of people
in the audience who
ultimately are either are
on the same journey you're
on or are considering
the same journey you're on.
So I think that's a little
bit of this, which is just
a couple of specific questions.
But one of them is, how do you
actually set about evaluating?
At the point where it
comes to the, OK, we've
got to pick a
cloud provider, how
did you set about evaluating
Google Cloud specifically,
doubtless others as well?
How do you set that
decision criteria?
How do you get that
process together?
What did you learn from that?
MEENA KISHANCHANDANI:
Yeah, I think
there's a lot of factors
that went into that.
We have been on a cloud
journey for a while, actually,
with some other providers.
But essentially, it
all came down to what
Google brought to the table.
You may have heard our CTO talk
in the keynote this morning--
the software engineering
mindset and a mindset of, hey,
challenging us to actually
think differently.
Because previously, we were
all thinking lift and shift,
and total cost of ownership
optimization, and all of that.
And we were really not
moving the dial forward.
So with Google coming in and
challenging us on that front
and showing that partnership.
And then the other
side is SAP, the scale
that I just talked about.
I mean, McKesson,
everything else around it
will move if SAP moves.
So to be able to--
so that became one of the big
use cases for the evaluation.
So last year, we did
a POC with Google.
And we were, within a
four to six weeks' time
frame, able to actually set
up SAP system, soup to nuts,
and test a lot of our
operational capabilities there.
So that became actually--
I am pretty sure that became
also one of the major inputs
back into the
decision-making process.
I'm sure there's a lot
more that went into it,
but I will say that this
was a pretty big use case.
PAUL YOUNG: I think
it's interesting.
I mean, if I net it
out, fundamentally,
the feedback from McKesson
at the end of it is you
guys entered this
with the question,
do you have the boxes?
And we exited with the question
of, do you have the processes?
MEENA KISHANCHANDANI: Right.
PAUL YOUNG: And
that's the difference.
Timo, do you have a--
TIMO SALZSIEDER:
Yeah, we're coming
from a different journey.
So we're pushing very hard, as I
said, this omnichannel journey.
So we started about
two years ago--
actually, three years ago--
this way, just to move
into the delivery business.
So food delivery business is
extremely relevant for us.
We're growing two-digit percent
every year now since then.
So we are currently
generating more than 6 billion
already out of
delivery business--
so quite strong growth over
the last two, three years.
And scalability is a
clear issue for us.
So for example, if you are
active in a country like India,
and you push the wrong
button, and you send out
a campaign to--
I don't know-- 20,
30 million people,
then obviously, you have a
scalability question to solve.
And therefore, it was pretty
clear that this cannot be done
with our existing
own data centers.
So we decided, OK, let's
move into the cloud space.
We were looking into that area,
and just, as you mentioned,
the engineering perspective
is extremely relevant for us.
And obviously, I think
it's pretty clear, just
looking into this event here--
I mean, the engineers,
they simply love Google.
So that was already kind of a
commitment from the engineering
perspective.
But cost played a role
also, and how are we
treated when it
comes, for example,
to the negotiations, et cetera.
Because this is, at least for me
personally, extremely relevant.
So Google did a pretty good job.
And therefore, we made the
decision, about two years ago,
to move our digital
products into Google Cloud,
mainly due to scalability
and also global scale,
although, just to be very
frank, we have some issues here,
obviously, with China and with
Russia because Google is not
present in these countries
at this point, at least.
So we hope that something is
moving there, hopefully soon.
But so the announcement
yesterday with [INAUDIBLE]
helps us a lot.
Because if, for example--
I don't know-- we could
partner with a public cloud
provider in China,
and then there
is a nice link using
[INAUDIBLE] into that
cloud environment helps,
obviously, our operation.
So therefore, this was
the starting point.
And then when the migration of
SAP R/3 to SAP S/4HANA came up,
we obviously asked
the question again.
Would it make sense now to
move into multi or hybrid cloud
environments, or
stay on premise,
or bring in even a second
public cloud provider?
But we made the decision,
OK, to stick with Google.
So therefore, we made the
decision also to move there
and obviously had some
discussions with Google.
And we produced,
at the beginning,
a couple of proof of concepts.
And our people were
pretty happy about that--
actually, very surprising.
Because initially from
our internal people,
there was more a
pushback when we
said, OK, we move to a public
cloud also on SAP space now.
Because the feedback
was, OK, now
we want to have our own boxes
and everything under control.
But as I said, we started a
couple of proof of concepts.
They were extremely easy.
And the initial proof
of concept initially
was planned to do it in two to
three months, and we did it--
I don't know-- in
one or two weeks.
And that convinced, obviously,
also our tech people
and the SAP guys.
And therefore, the
decision was pretty clear.
PAUL YOUNG: Yeah, I think we
met, oh, at SAPPHIRE last year.
So that was June.
That was May last year.
And we said, hey, we
think we can do this.
And I remember at
the time, we're
like, OK, let's give it a go.
And yeah, I mean, 16 weeks
later, we concluded it all out
and were proceeding forward.
I mean, that's lightning
speed in SAP world.
But anyway, so in full
disclosure, I mean,
these are massive
projects, right?
They're going to
go on for years.
So just give us a sense on--
so in your case, you've
been running now for, like,
six months?
And you've been
running for six weeks,
basically, effectively,
since we've
put the first boxes to use.
I mean, just want to give us
an update on where you are
and what you've learned so far?
TIMO SALZSIEDER: Yeah.
So the technology actually
is not the problem.
It's more to consolidate
and harmonize
the different processes across
the different countries.
So we spent quite a lot
of time convincing people
and come to a standard approach.
Because obviously, you
have a couple of CFOs
from the countries that want
to have a different setup
of the SAP environment.
So therefore, a lot of
conceptual work convincing
these guys that it
makes sense to go
into one standard
approach, which,
obviously, huge implications
on the processes
in the individual countries.
But there we are, and
we're in the middle
of the implementation right now.
We're doing-- and this is
historically within Metro.
We're doing a lot of
the stuff ourselves.
So we're building up now
huge resources in India
to customize and
implement SAP S/4HANA.
And this is ongoing.
And we are hiring, every couple
of days, a couple of people,
and just make sure that we have
a good SAP practice in-house
and using not too many
partners to do this,
but obviously, get a
lot of support from SAP
directly, and also
obviously from Google.
PAUL YOUNG: Yeah.
Meena?
MEENA KISHANCHANDANI: So
I think, as you mentioned,
our journey is very recent.
In terms of actually
process, I think
we have good alignment
from the standardization
and harmonization perspective.
But that's not happened
overnight either,
so that's been a
long journey forward.
PAUL YOUNG: Your
journey started way
before you started
talking to us.
MEENA KISHANCHANDANI:
Way before, yeah.
Way, way before.
Actually, it started, I
think, three or four years ago
in Europe.
So where they started the
implementation of ECC,
that was the intent, that--
and that started in Norway.
And that just
completed, I think,
sometime mid of last year.
And then it was paused, and then
the pivot to S/4 over there.
So from a process
perspective, I think
we were good when we started our
technical evaluation for where
it's going to be deployed.
So yeah, so it is very recent.
So far, I think
the speed at which
we've been able to deploy even
the development environments--
they're non-sandbox.
They're actually
development environments.
Our timeline was very
aggressive that was given to us,
considering that we
did a POC with Google,
concluded that
only last November.
And we were told that all
the entire development stack
and systems have
to be built by May.
So that was a pretty tall order.
But so far, I think with
the partnership with Google,
all the engineering teams
that have been brought in
to work with our internal
teams to enable the platform
and get our deployments
going, I think
that's been an amazing
experience for us.
And the ability to
actually upskill
some of the teams that
have been working that's
going to be actually--
so the independence,
the self-reliance aspect of
it is also very important.
So that's been also achieved
in the short duration.
So overall, I would
say so far, so good.
Time will tell.
PAUL YOUNG: I'm going
to ask Timo a question
and come back to that
point you just made.
But Timo, I've heard you
say this a couple of times,
so I think it's fascinating
for the audience, which
is the part of this for you
isn't just in the technology
changes [INAUDIBLE],,
but it's actually
changing the culture at Metro.
And partnering with
Google was as much
of a change in the culture
as it was the technology.
Do you want to explain that?
TIMO SALZSIEDER: Sure.
So like most others
probably also in the room,
we have this [INAUDIBLE] talent.
So we're really looking
actively for a lot of people.
And we started our digital
journey with a lot of externals
helping us to build
up these platforms.
And we're now in the middle
of internalizing that.
And if you have people
in the organization
that are working
for Metro since--
I don't know--
20, 30, 40 years--
and we really have people
working more than 40 years
for us, which is already a
bit strange to me, at least.
But you talk to these people.
And obviously, you see
that they are, well,
fixed on a specific mindset.
And to change this,
it's obviously
good to have an impact also
from the outside world.
So we get this push a bit
also from people like Google.
So therefore, we're sending
people to the Google offices.
We try to do workshop together.
We're running a couple
of innovation labs
currently with Google.
So therefore, this
helps us a lot
in at least driving
that space a bit
into that innovation direction.
But when it comes to culture,
it's a bit even more.
So we even did a rebranding
of our IT subsidiaries.
So it was formally called Metro
Systems, which is obviously not
that sexy, now called Metronom.
And we combined a
couple of organizations
into that organization.
And if you walk across our
campus at headquarters,
you see a lot of people
wearing Metronom hoodies
and T-shirts, et cetera.
And that was, two or three
years ago, impossible.
And therefore, we are
pushing very, very hard
on brand experience.
So we want to be just
a good employer brand,
and we are very
aggressive on that topic.
I do a lot of internal
service with our people.
And actually, we do
this on a monthly basis,
so not on an annual
survey basis,
just to figure out how well
we're treating the people,
and we're investing quite a lot.
And in terms of that,
obviously, a partner like Google
helps us a lot.
Because I mean,
I think Google is
known for having an
exceptional culture.
And we don't want to
copy the Google culture.
I think that's impossible
with our setup.
But at least, there are
some things to learn.
And also, when it comes to
hiring processes and all
these HR processes,
we're just looking
at what Google is doing.
And there's a very
strong relationship.
And what we're doing
now, since about a year,
is we are introducing objectives
and key results, OKRs, which
is pretty famous at Google.
And I think if you talk
to the founders of Google,
they at least tell
you that OKRs was
one of the key
principles at Google
to drive this organization.
So there is a lot of
exchange, and we're
learning a lot from Google.
And therefore, it's
more about, yeah,
exchanging culture,
exchanging processes,
rather than only having a
technology collaboration.
PAUL YOUNG: Yeah, I think
one of things you said
was that basically, every
time-- the Google guys
are sitting in the audience.
But every time the
Google guys came
to visit Metro during
the sales process,
they were always wearing
Google T-shirts, which
is one of the things that
really resonated for Metro,
is that they were very
proud of their brand
and they wanted to display it.
And then your own people
started to replicate that.
And it's a really
interesting conversation
because we were
having this yesterday.
I mean, anything you do with
SAP is hopefully a long-term
marriage, right--
multiple ways.
There's partners.
There's SAP.
There's us.
There's everything
else involved.
So on the one hand, it's
a long-term marriage.
On the other hand, I
mean, ultimately, you
want us to be electricity
service, right?
I mean, ultimately, you want
to go to SAP and turn it on,
and it works, and it updates,
and it does everything.
And so it's a little
bit of a challenge,
frankly, for me as we look
at the business growing out,
which is, what do you
really want from us?
Because on the one
hand, what you want
is stability and,
effectively, never
to have to talk to us
because the stuff just runs.
On the other hand, we do
have to maintain contact,
and we do have to grow together.
And so if you have a
concept, I'm interested.
But it's a long-term
challenge for me,
which is, after
the sale is done,
what is it you
actually want from us
in a long-term
relationship to make SAP
successful in the long term?
TIMO SALZSIEDER: I think
you just nailed it.
Because we consider, at
least in that context--
when I talk about
digital and I'm
talking about
warehouse management,
I think it's a different
topic, or supply
chain as other examples.
But when it comes to financial
services and financial
processes internally,
it simply needs to run.
It needs to be up and running.
So therefore, the
example you just
brought with electricity
or water, that's
what we're expecting from you--
is making sure that this works,
and that it runs
without any hassle,
and that it provides
good scalability,
that security is fine so
that nobody is stealing stuff
from us.
So that's our requirement
at this point.
But as I said,
long-term, I could
imagine that we're driving this
relationship between Google,
SAP, and Metro even
to the next level.
And then we have a
bit of more demands,
because then it comes
into innovation;
that we are talking
about new things
that we deploy to
specific countries;
that we have also, on this
cultural level, some exchange.
So this is what we're expecting.
But at this point when it comes
to the finance applications,
it's all about making sure
that it works in a proper way,
and that it runs smooth
for our customers.
And I'm talking about
internal customers.
So therefore, I
just simply don't
want to get any stress with
the CFOs in the countries.
I just want to
hear from them in--
I don't know-- one
or two or three years
when we're done
with that process,
and that it works
smooth, and that they
don't have any problems at all.
Because it's good, as a CIO,
that if you hear nothing,
then it's perfect.
And that's what I
would like to achieve.
PAUL YOUNG: And Meena,
I think you equally--
I mean, we're at the start
of the journey with McKesson.
But obviously, you and me were
[INAUDIBLE] five weeks ago.
And we started this process
where basically, the road
track for you is we did
a hackathon, basically,
where we had our team
and your team together.
It was fascinating.
I mean, literally, I think,
three hours into the hackathon,
my team was elbowed out of the
way, and your guys took over.
And it was an amazing process.
But again, how are
you going to build,
I guess, internally at McKesson
to get the transitional change
to happen?
And then, how do you
think the long term works?
MEENA KISHANCHANDANI:
Yeah, I think essentially,
that was the start
of it, the hackathon
that you talked about, just
to get that base excited.
It's an amazing thing to
watch when they actually
get to do this themselves.
Literally, even
after that week, I
think there's so
much of feedback
I've gotten from that team that
they felt so empowered just
going through that process
and being able to actually--
SAP, I know it can be pretty
mundane in terms of technology
and all of that.
It's pretty-- it
has a long history.
But just to be able to use
the cloud capabilities to be
able to build some
level of automation
that we built even
that weekend, we
continued to hone
on more and more.
I think that is
exciting people there.
And also on top of that now,
our go-forward strategy is,
let SAP do what it's best for.
And then anything else, anything
differentiating capabilities
that you want to build for
your competitive advantage
in the market, take it out.
Don't build there.
And so that is also going to
give the teams an opportunity
to actually learn new skills.
And they may not become
developers overnight
and use the--
but there is definitely
a desire there
when you start to
paint that picture.
So you have to give
them those opportunities
to be able to skill as well.
And that's what we are
focused on as well.
There are a lot of teams
that do that type of work,
so we are trying to see
where there is interest
within the existing teams
and help them get plugged
into those groups and get
some experience working
on some of those projects.
The other thing is what
we've been doing also,
almost like a "Shark
Tank" kind of concept
where we have been
letting people
pitch some ideas
about what they want
to do on the cloud platform.
And of course, it has to
have some value that we are
going to eventually deliver.
But those are the
ideas we are getting
from people and from the teams.
And then we are picking a
couple to invest in and let
them work on it.
So I mean, all of this is really
helping build that excitement.
And obviously, then it attracts
external talent as well.
And so yeah, so
there's a lot of things
we are trying to do to
energize the teams there.
PAUL YOUNG: Very cool.
So I guess two final
questions, one of which
is incredibly dangerous
because, A, there's
a camera in the back of
the room recording this.
And B, I'm going to ask the
question that the general rule
say, never ask this question.
But for me personally,
one of my personal things
always is when I get
feedback, is like, yeah,
I like the nice things.
Tell me what we
need to do better.
It's all about improvement.
And actually, one of my team
actually recently asked me
how they were doing.
I was like, you're doing great.
And they're, yeah, yeah, yeah.
Tell me about what
I need to do better.
I'm like, OK, I
like that attitude.
In that spirit, what do
you need us to do better?
What can we do more for
you as we go forward here?
MEENA KISHANCHANDANI:
So I think--
well, our journey is recent.
So I think we'll
continue to discover--
PAUL YOUNG: You'll
get back to me?
[LAUGHS]
MEENA KISHANCHANDANI: Yeah.
But I think our goal is really
to learn from your teams,
and then get--
if not completely,
but have a fair amount
of self-independence.
So we want Google to take
that approach with us as well,
focus more on how we can learn.
And so that's one thing.
And then continue to
challenge our mindset,
continue to do that.
Because sometimes, we can
be fixated in some things.
And so continue to do that.
And for me, that's been
something I've seen
and I hope to continue to see.
PAUL YOUNG: Yeah,
one of the feedbacks
we've heard loud and
hard from customers
is we need to start doing
customer panels and customer
get-togethers,
and start sharing.
And driving that community
and knowledge better
is clearly one of the
things we have to do.
I got it.
Timo?
I'm sure you have feedback.
TIMO SALZSIEDER: Yeah.
PAUL YOUNG: And you get the
chance to speak it out loud,
so--
TIMO SALZSIEDER:
Yeah, that's true.
So I could repeat a couple of
things that you just mentioned.
But one topic we would
like to see a bit more
is more business talk.
Because, I mean,
at the end, Google
is a very engineering-driven
organization, which is fine.
And actually, our engineers
love the way Google
is doing business.
But now from a top
management perspective,
it would be just nice to
get a bit more support
and a bit more
insights when it comes
to business-related functions.
So therefore, we
highly appreciate
what just has been communicated
in the keynote meetings
yesterday and today, these
industry-specific solutions
that will be developed by
Google and by partners.
So this is something we're
really looking forward to,
because as I said,
our business is not
a classical retail business.
So we're really looking
to get more innovation
into our organization,
et cetera.
And therefore, we're expecting,
from a strategic partner
like Google and SAP, that
we're getting a bit more
feedback and a bit
more consultancy
when it comes to
business-specific questions we
might have.
And also what you
just mentioned,
customer panels, et cetera,
to exchange with other peers
would be very helpful.
But, well, building
industry-specific solutions
for the retail industry that
fit also our specific needs,
that would be just perfect.
Because so far,
excellent technology,
no question about that.
And I as, also, a
computer science guy,
appreciate that in keynotes,
there are some unique shells
and you see some
commands typed in.
But obviously, I would like
to see a bit more business
talk in the future, and
that's our requirement.
PAUL YOUNG: Cool.
And so clock is running down.
Last question.
You're on a journey.
There's a lot of people
sitting in the audience who
are probably thinking,
yeah, I'm going
to have to do the same thing.
There's some people in this
audience who are thinking,
I want to do the same thing.
And there's some people in
the audience who are thinking,
I have to do the same
thing whether I want it
or not, right?
Knowing what you
know now, what's
your best advice to them?
TIMO SALZSIEDER: It's
actually quite simple.
So just make sure that you
take the team with you.
That would be my major advice.
So it was not a
top-down decision.
It was, OK, let's move into
the Google Cloud environment.
We really asked our people.
We got really some buy-in.
We built a lot of prototypes.
So if you have the
buy-in from your team
and your organization, then it's
actually a fairly easy move.
But if you do it
top-down and say, OK--
I mean, I don't know.
If everybody would be
a huge Microsoft fan,
and then we make the
decision towards Google,
then this would be a disaster.
But in our case, we simply
informed the people up front.
We asked for their
opinion, and just
made sure that we have a
lot of proof of concepts,
and just got the
buy-in from the team.
And if you have that,
then it's an easy going.
So I mean, we're
not through yet.
So I'm expecting, obviously,
over the next couple
of months and years, some
issues within the project, which
is pretty normal.
But I know that the team
is highly motivated.
And I know, when we first
communicated in the SAP space
that we're moving towards
cloud, we got a huge pushback.
But then when the guys
saw the technology
and could play around
with the technology,
it was fairly easy for them.
And therefore, we
have now, well,
transformed basically our
SAP guys from on-premise fans
into Google fans.
And this obviously helps
to run such a huge project.
PAUL YOUNG: Cool.
Meena?
MEENA KISHANCHANDANI:
So I think very similar.
So for us, it had to be a little
bit of a top-down as well.
Because I think that's
also needed because people
are looking for that
prescriptive direction
as well at times.
So that's helped.
So it's both ways--
energizing our--
it's the bottom-up and
top-down approach that's
really worked well for us.
And then the other thing
is, don't think too much.
Get started.
And it's OK to fail fast.
Try things out, and you will
not know until you actually
try things out.
And there's a lot to learn.
And like I mentioned, McKesson
has been on this cloud journey
for a while.
But it will take some time.
So think less, start, but
then go slow in terms of you
have to really pace
it out in terms
of what you want to achieve.
So I think that's at least what
I see has been working for us.
PAUL YOUNG: Thanks.
I'll tell you, one
of the things for me
is we are 30-second provisioning
globally for any SAP system.
It's all per-second billing, all
the way up to our entire fleet.
So unlike a classic SAP
project where you start
thinking about it this year.
You size it out.
You get sticker shock.
You put it in the budget.
You maybe do it next year.
You can do this this afternoon
on a credit card, right?
And it's that-- adjusting to the
removement of the restrictions
is kind of hard, right?
I think right back at the
start the conversation.
It's not about the technology.
It's about the process.
And once you understand
what's possible,
you can go from there.
Hey, thank you for your time,
for spending the time with us
this afternoon.
Timo, Meena,
sincerely appreciate
you giving this
insight and wisdom
and spending the time with us.
Really appreciate it.
Like I said, you can
go this afternoon
and start an SAP
server in 30 seconds.
That's never been
done before at scale.
There's no reason
not to give it a go.
In the meantime, I will tell you
that the next organizers would
dearly appreciate if you
would provide feedback
on this session so we
know what you liked
and what you didn't like and
what we should do next year.
But at our rate of growth at
SAP, I think there'll be a few
more of these to come
as we go forward.
So thanks for your time.
And my last call-- actually,
I have to say this.
If you're interested
at all, why wait?
Yesterday, Andy and Sidney,
we had a conversation
with Andy and Sidney.
And when I asked Andy
a similar question,
his answer was, tell me exactly
what your plan B is, right?
Because if plan A is wait
and see if I need to do this,
at some point, you're going
to have to change, right?
And so if it is this simple
and it is this possible,
why are we all waiting?
Competitive advantage is
on your side if you do it.
And if you want to
do that, call me.
We'll more than happily
come out and visit you.
But thank you all.
And Meena and Timo,
thank you one more time.
[APPLAUSE]
[MUSIC PLAYING]